voici millau sont japonaises en charge
d'étudier l'environnement magnétisé de
mercure hui laboratoire cnrs ont
travaillé sur la conception des
appareils de mesures qui seront utilisés
dont celui de physique et chimie de
l'environnement et de l'espace à orléans
le roller l'ernée dent may be colombo
c'est un instrument qui va mesurer la
densité du milieu autour de mercure donc
c'est une petite sonde météo qui
fonctionne avec les antennes électriques
qui sont montés de part et d'autre de
cette petite sonde japonaise des
antennes électrique pour récupérer les
données et effectuer les mesures
demandées grâce à un appareil conçu dans
le loiret cette carte électronique est
au coeur d'un projet qui s'inscrive dans
la continuité c'est un héritage d'un
instrument qu'on avait embarqué sur
rosetta qui s'appelle nippes et c'est
une évolution de cet instrument pour
réaliser le même type de mesure sur
mercure de la conception de l'appareil à
l'exploitation future des données ils
sont une quinzaine investi dans la
mission bepi colombo depuis maintenant
une dizaine d'années plusieurs or
l'année seront en guyane pour le
lancement de la fusée ariane 5 dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi
si tout va bien une belle récompense
c'est une fierté c'est des projets qui
sont longs les voir aboutir et obtenir
des résultats
lorsqu'ils sont bons c'est une
satisfaction le savoir-faire orléanais
séduit à tel point qu'une nouvelle
mission est déjà en vue sur jupiter et
ses lunes glacées
en attendant cet objectif mercure est la
mission est menée conjointement par
l'europe et le japon l'arrivée sur cette
planète qu'on ne connaît pas très bien
est prévue en 2025
mais le travail aura débuté bien avant
une conférence internationale
rassemblant l'ensemble des études sur la
planète est d'ailleurs prévue à orléans
en juin 2001